Chances are because you're here on YouTube,
you already know all about Casey Neistat.
He's the big dog OG in the vlog space.
He's a personal friend, he's a past podcast guest
and truly one of the biggest creators on this platform.
But what do you know about his older brother Van?
Well, you may know that their careers actually began
in partnership with each other,
creating and collaborating on videos that would go viral
before viral was even a thing,
before YouTube even existed.
You may also know that they had an HBO series
in 2010 called "The Neistat Brothers."
But after that show was not picked up for a second season,
Casey went on to become Casey "Casey" in quote marks.
Van on the other hand, embarked on a very different journey
an artistic journey, a journey of self discovery,
a journey that for the most part was
outside the public sphere
until recently that is,
when he launched this thing called "The Spirited Man"
which is a curious, unlimited series here on YouTube,
that in addition to growing like gangbusters right now
explores all kinds of interesting questions.
Questions large, questions small,
everything from home repair to critical thinking
with a very interesting introspective
and philosophical flair that I think is truly singular,
utterly unique and just fascinating.
I'm thoroughly compelled by this series, "The Spirited Man".
Please check it out and subscribe to it
and found myself so curious
about this guy Van and his sensibility
that I reached out to Casey to connect us.
And here we are, and what a joyous occasion it is.
So hit that subscribe button
and please enjoy my conversation with Van Neistat.
(dramatic music)
Such a pleasure to meet you.
Thank you for doing this.
I'm so excited to talk to you.
Likewise.
Thank you.
You're like this mythic mysterious figure.
I mean, I've known your brother for eight or so years.
He was an early guest on the podcast.
I think he's been on three or four times
although not all of those episodes were
before he started vloging, they are way back.
So I've been familiar with you and your work
for quite some time, but you are this kind of question mark
in the sense that in the wake of "The Neistat Brothers",
you kind of went your own way
and left all of us to make up stories
about what exactly happened.
You know, like project, some notion of what you were doing.
And in my mind you were like this, you know,
out of the public eye, off the grid, dude,
who kind of walked off the mortal coil, like Kung Fu
to pursue like purity and art and truth and answers
to questions of the universe.
And now you've resurfaced, with this beautiful channel
which made me think like I really
wanted to finally meet you.
So thank you.
Well, I'm so psyched to be here
and I'm really glad that that myth is what it is
because that's the best case scenario.
But I think in reality is I just find it really
difficult to earn a living.
And I think that the 10 years, between the, 11 years,
between "The Neistat Brothers" and then this channel,
I've just spent exploring all the different options
of making a living and with my craft
and then working at all the different
sort of aspects of being a writer, director.
Cause there's, you know, there's so much to the
it's such a complicated art form.
You have to be a writer, you have to be a director,
you have to be camera man.
And then in our case, like with Casey or with me,
you know, you're also the personality on the screen,
but mainly I was trying to learn how to like tell
stories from, you know technically what is going on with,
with storytelling.
And, you know, I work with this artist named Tom Sachs
and he was like almost a patron because he would hire me
to do these projects, but he gave me an extreme
level of authorship with these projects.
And it really helped me to develop.
And it was 10 years of almost exclusively working with him
and he would go out and get money.
He would get sponsorship from Nike.
He would get sponsorship from Hurley
and we travel all over the world.
And then at the same time I would write my own projects
but really trying to learn like the technical
storytelling process.
Tom Sachs is a very interesting, curious, unique artist.
I've been a fan of his for a long time.
He inspired these glasses.
He wears, I don't know if he still does
but he used to wear these exact frames.
And I went on a search
for like a year to figure out where he got them from.
And I finally figured it out
and these are
the glasses that I wear
and I just get new ones from the same place.
Yeah.
So I've been following his career for a long time.
And it's interesting to see the genesis
of this DIY aesthetic that shows up in your work
and of course in Casey's work
and how it all traces back to Tom.
Like when you look at Tom,
like a lot of the kind of details that show up
in both you and your brother's videos,
really there's plenty of evidence
in the Tom Sachs catalog
from where that came from.
So I'm interested in the influence
that guy had on, on both of you.
You know I really, I distinctly remember going
into his studio the first time ever.
And his reputation had preceded him
and a friend of mine who told me about this guy, Tom Sachs .
And he was like an artist.
And he was like a famous artist.
His work was in museums and galleries
and collectors paid thousands of dollars for his art.
And in my mind that had all, people who reached that level
of success in the art paradigm.
It was always a very thick degree of inaccessibility.
Like I took art history classes in college
but there was always this really,
there was this thick
thick mystery as to why.
Okay, okay.
I get you what you're telling me about Mark Rothko
and this big blurry red spot, I get that
but why, why, why, why?
I don't feel it.
I don't feel like why that is art.
And I don't feel wow that is going in a museum.
And when I went into Sachs 's studio
it was this unbelievably familiar feeling
when I was looking at some of the pieces
on his wall and I thought, oh, I get it.
I get it.
I get, I get why this is art in a museum.
And I also get where it comes from
and what he had, the piece that, that is in my mind,
that is etched.
He had one of those handheld from like the eighties
defender video. video games, I guess
is what you'd technically call them.
But really they were just L E D dots that you
could move around and then like figured out how to make it.
Right.
Like the little football, remember that NFL game.
Yeah. Yeah.
Like one step above that.
Those are like the digital watch kind of displays
but this was like the light displays.
And it had, let's say it had eight buttons on it.
He had made linkage with armature and little hinges
and pennies for thumb buttons to control those buttons
on the thing mounted to like a frame
made out of police barricades that he had stolen.
Like that was one of the pieces that was in there.
And then I got to like look through the catalogs,
you know, beautiful,
everything in the art industry is the highest,
the art handlers are the best movers,
the most expensive
and most careful movers you can hire.
The people who clean are the highest custodian level
custodians that exist.
And so the, the books are like,
there's this company called Steidel,
have you heard of them?
I think they're in Austria.
And they're like very limited edition catalogs
and looking through his,
and he had like this Chanel guillotine that he made
that was in the permanent collection at the Pompidou center.
And it's like, wow, I've been to Paris.
I've seen that building, he's in there.
And then to learn from him,
it was like almost the complete opposite.
It was like, the whole thing was flipped in like,
no artists are not people smoking pot
and staying up all night watching movies
and being pretentious in cafes in Paris.
Artists are up at the crack of Dawn.
They work harder than everyone.
They're all broke, but some of them are rich
and it's extreme discipline and extreme.
And like, the thing I learned from Tom was all this
like meticulousness, like it's an incredible illusion
that his work looks like it was made by a 14 year
old kid that's in prison.
And he just has his own, his own resources.
And that's what it looks like, but it's all very
carefully refined over , he's been doing it for 50 years,
40 years or something, 50 years
There is feeling of chaos, but when you drill down
into the most micro aspects of his work,
the attention to detail is unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
And you know, I mean I don't even know how to describe
his genre or what it is that he does specifically.
I mean, he takes artifacts from pop culture,
and reformulates them to make a statement
about whatever it is that he's interested in pursuing.
He made a Sub-Zero freezer, refrigerator from scratch.
You know, he like got the copper tubing and like
sweated the joints and it's all beautiful.
And it's made out of plywood.
And I think the name of the piece is Darth Vader,
but oh okay.
Okay.
The sort of hidden soul of his work that to me is everything
the hidden soul of the work is that all of those little
artifacts that you see everything,
they work and they look the way they do because they work
they function that refrigerator, his standard was this thing
is not done unless it can freeze ice cubes.
And we made a, a McDonald's from scratch,
like a street cart McDonald's from scratch.
And it, yeah, it looks like a work of art, but when it was
in the Guggenheim in Berlin, every Thursday night
we opened that McDonald's and we served hamburgers
and we served.
It was a functioning McDonald's right?
And that was a two year process of putting
that show together. Wasn't it?
Let me see, I started in 2000.
Yeah. I started in 2001 in April.
And then it was in, at the Bowen foundation in Manhattan.
Yeah, I think in February, 2003.
Yeah, and then in summer, 2003, it went to Berlin.
What is the obsession with NASA all about that he has?
It's unreal.
I hate space, I hate the space program
Well you made the whole documentary there.
I know. Mark Parker is to blame for that.
Mark Parker went to the show.
He's like, you guys got to make a feature about this.
And we're like okay, then we did it.
Well, there's an interesting story on how
how you met him and started working with him.
Can you tell, can you tell that story?
So I worked at Scholastic, the publisher that publishes
Harry Potter, they also make the little classroom magazines
that you would get when you were a kid.
And I worked on a magazine called Super Science
which was for fourth to sixth graders.
And one of my jobs was I had to do a science
experiment every month that the kids could
do with just supplies they'd find
in their classroom or in their house.
So my desk would have all of these like little, you know
solar ovens on them and little, the little coffee can
with the rubber band and the weight inside that rolls
and then rolls back to you.
And a friend of ours, a friend of mine, Joe Torx,
and he worked in marketing
and I had lunch with him every day.
And one day he brought in Tom Sachs
and that's how I found out who he was.
And I just kind of met him, "Nice to meet you, blah, blah"
And then when my job was, I had stretched my internship
into a five day a week, like basically full-time job.
And my editor was like, look for legal purposes,
you either have to become like dedicate yourself
and become an associate editor here for salary
and all that stuff,
or I have to fire you just for legal reasons.
And I was like I don't really wanna do this.
And Joe said, go work for Sachs .
He's doing a job, he's doing a big project.
And so I, it was around that time I came down
and on my bicycle, I had mounted this,
for an old DV video camera,
I had mounted this bike mount to record myself riding
through the Holland tunnel on a bicycle.
And he was, Sachs was examining it on the street
like in the wild.
And I was just like, wow, that's my, I made that.
He's like, I've found my kind.
And so when I went to apply,
I'm the guy who did that thing.
So it's sort of like, maybe this guy has
the rudimentary ability.
And I think what he liked about me was that I didn't go
to art school.
I was unrefined and I'm kind of like,
I can get the thing done, but in the, like really
in just a terrible way that he loved.
Right. Uncorrupted by the fineries of how you're supposed
to do it.
Right. So you start out as like a formulator
cutting like foam board and stuff like that
and spent two years putting together
this gallery piece that then ends up in Berlin
at the Guggenheim.
Right?
Yeah.
And then in the meantime,
you're making films.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was, I brought my video camera to work
and I made an unauthorized movie, you know,
I was on the clock and there was, I was measuring foam core
and there was a tape measure and I finished my measurement
and I put the tape measure down.
And on the tape measure,
it was a Stanley power luck tape measure.
And where it normally says power lock,
it said, Kubrick is dead.
So it was the Stanley Kubrick is dead tape measure.
And so I made a movie about that.
And then about how weird the space that we were
working in was, and then for the soundtrack,
I just lifted the Berlioz music from "The Shining."
And then the monologue of the head of the hotel saying,
man, he killed a family and stacked them
in the north hallway or whatever
But this isn't part of why Tom hired you.
That was like a little moonlighting thing, right,
that he ends up seeing?
And then he saw it and he was like, okay,
keep making these, you still gotta do the fabrication.
You still got to make all this stuff,
but keep making these videos.
And then he helped refine my process
because he would give me viewing assignments.
And he would say things like, okay,
this work is about the sculpture.
So get really really close, as close as you can
show the hot glue, show the screws, show the, you know,
the burrs.
And he showed us the Eames short films
that the "Powers of 10."
Ray and Charles Eames made in Venice,
"Powers of 10" is one of them.
There's one called "Introduction to Feedback."
And then they made, in my opinion
what is the greatest industrial film of all time?
And it's called the "SX 70"
and it's about the Polaroid SX 70.
And it was just made for the employees of Polaroid
which I don't really understand why
maybe they would show it at a party or something
but it's this miraculous movie about exactly
how the Polaroid SX 70 works
but there's also a humanity in it
because the things that they're photographing for the movie
are children like pushing over a whole stack
of cardboard boxes or, you know
flipping over rocks at the beach.
And then the Polaroid is taking pictures of those,
and then they show you like the three layers
of Polaroid film and how the light meter closes the iris.
And it was just unbelievable,
the humanity and the technical
virtuosity of the film combining and that is sort of
I think in essence, that's the thing
I'm subconsciously making all the time that
and with a combination of like Mr. Rogers
for adults, like, that's my ambition.
Well, that was the original idea behind, well
maybe not "The Spirited Man," but you had a pilot, right.
That you were pitching that was basically that idea.
The idea of like, fix it man, for adults kind of show.
Yeah. I made this pilot called "Week and Fix It"
and it wasn't good enough cause I was smoking
way too much pot at the time.
So it had that, it just wasn't good enough
but I've been able to, you know, I steal from it
and put little bits of it in "The Spirited Man."
Like there's this episode called sobriety
where you see me like chopping down a door
and then it cuts to these little dolls
in the same hallway and it stopped motion.
And when I posted that video,
Isabel, my wife said, did you just make all that?
And I was like, no, no, no,
That's from that's from 2011.
Yeah.
The archive is unbelievable.
I mean, that's one of the things I've noticed with Casey
like in making the videos
like you guys created this incredible library
that then informs all the videos that you make
that you're able to tap into
all of these memories and, you know,
access all of these events
throughout the course of your life.
Do you mean like the library of movies
that other people made?
No, no, no.
The library of home movies of you guys growing up
and then just the way that you've maintained,
like a catalog of all the work up to date
so that you can access it
and weave it into the new projects that you're making.
That's crazy you mentioned that because this week
I was confronted with some of the limitations
of that and they, things fall away.
Like you lose no matter how careful
unless you stay in one spot.
I think like Kubrick had that big mansion
in England and he just stayed there and he didn't leave.
So I'm sure he had everything, but I'm, you know
I'm a gen X or nomad generation and I'm moving all the time.
And so I've been moving hard drives around
with all my footage on them.
And then I had this studio in the south Bronx
and the hard drives went from the size of like an
encyclopedia Britannica to the size of a pack of cigarettes.
So I could take six, 500 gig encyclopedia Britannica
hard drives and put them on one pack of cigarettes,
hard drives.
Right.
And I did that and then something happened
that they like got corrupted.
Oh no.
And I was just, and now we're in the process of trying
to rescue a lot of footage.
Like it's like from 2007 to 2013 or something like that.
(speakers speaking over each other)
So much raw footage, it's horrible,
but I have a lot of movies.
I have a movie archive with that I can pull,
I can like completely edited videos that I can pull
footage from that way.
And then I have the tapes that go to 2007, I think.
And then 2007, I think we switched over to card-based video.
So I've been going and taking tapes down
to like this company that can like turn them
into, cause I don't have any of the gear,
to play the tapes anymore.
Right. But with your appreciation for being meticulous
in every regard, it's, amazing that this is
this has been a blind spot.
You got to get on top of this.
What's horrible about it is that I've been like
I've been crazy about it.
I've been like focused and yelling at people
and making sure things happen.
And, don't forget this and dah, dah, dah
I put tremendous amount of effort in,
and then despite that like certain things,
just kind of, you just,you just lose them,
but I'm confident we'll get,
I'll get that one hard drive.
It's just one hard drive, but it's three terabytes
of like really small videos.
Somebody's got to be able to figure that out.
Yeah, I think so.
Well, let's take it back.
I wanna go back to the origin story a little bit.
You growing up in Connecticut and we're, you know
in looking at your work
and reflecting on your brother's career path,
the overlaps, the differences,
like there's a shared appreciation
for not just detail and precision in the work that you do
but also this unbelievable capacity
and understanding of storytelling
and the importance of telling stories that are meaningful.
Like where do you, where does that come from?
I think, well, I think my mom and my dad who are no
longer together, like they're two hemispheres of the brain
and my mom is like the right hemisphere of the brain
which is like very creative and artistic.
And she is an unbelievably gifted,
natural storyteller with no technique.
Like she, I'm sorry with no discipline.
Like she doesn't write.
I mean, she writes, but not as she should write.
She doesn't do, she takes pictures,
but not as she should.
She, you know, she doesn't make films,
she doesn't let up above,
but her natural gift, like to just sit
and tell you a story.
Unbelievable. Unbelievably, good.
How she can weave.
And she'll put a little, she'll put like a little seed
over here.
That just seems like an interesting little detail.
And then it comes back at the end of the thing
and it's unbelievably great.
So that's mom.
And then my dad is like the left hemisphere,
but like, he, if you ask him, like, was his favorite movie
in the last five years, he'd be like Caddyshack.
You know, he's seen like eight movies in his life,
read like 10 books, but he's extremely orderly
and he's very responsible and he works really hard.
So I, you know, I think
A meeting of the mystical with the rigor.
Yeah.
And I think those, those probably mom
and dad are responsible for why,
but in my mother's entire side of the family
is they're, you know, Irish, Portuguese,
and they have, they just have that storytelling gift.
But my dad is also extremely funny and extremely charming.
Everyone loves him.
So, so by osmosis, it filters down, right?
But the original plan was to do what, like writing?
Yeah, so, you know, there wasn't,
filmmaking was this thing that you need
in order to have access to, it seemed, you know,
you had to go to film school
and there were like really two film schools.
There was USC, which was like the west coast guys,
like Spielberg and Coppola.
And those guys, I don't even know if they went there,
but, and then there was the east coast was NYU
and they were just both prohibitively expensive.
It was just, it was not, it was not an option.
I didn't know about Vernor Hertzog.
I didn't know you could just get a camera
and do blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So when I was in high school, I, you know, a friend
of mine who read a lot, he told me to read Hunter Thompson
and I read Hunter Thompson.
And I was just like, okay, well
this is something I would love to do.
I would love to do this.
And then I said, okay, so I'm going to go to school.
And I'm just going to learn all the liberal arts stuff
and try to go out and be a writer, I'll move to New York.
Right. And like, get, you know
back then writers made a lot of money.
Writers did well, you could write
for magazines and have a nice awesome house
It's so crazy, right?
Yeah.
That's no longer.
And I just didn't, I don't like writing.
I mean, I do now I write every day now,
but back then, like sitting down
and I did it professionally and just the revisions
and the revisions and working with the computer
just doing it all in the computer.
It just..,
It offends you.
Oh, I hate it.
It offends your analog sensibility.
You know, it's not, it's not pretension.
It's like I developed from zero to like 20.
I sent my first email when I was 23 years old.
So I developed without any of that computer stuff
and computers to this day, like people talk about how
when they hear the ding on their phone
it gives them a small, like endorphins rush.
For me, it is the opposite.
When I hear a ding on my hone, it is dread.
It is like, oh this is another thing I got to deal with.
And I got to go through this device.
That's probably going to break
or malfunction or not work somewhere along the way.
And the typewriter, like, I love the typewriter
because the typewriter is just, once you get your fingers
knowing where the keys are, it's just direct thought.
And you can type the way that you think
and talk because you can't just go back.
You can't just like if you start down a path,
you'd just be like, "and Tim and I went down to the, no, no
it wasn't Tim, it was Billy."
You have to write that,
whereas if you were with the computer
you'd be like, oh no, it wasn't Tim, it was Billy.
And you go back and it's so, and, then when you're done
with the typewriter, let's say you get dinner's ready.
You just stand up and go, and there it is.
You don't have to remember to save it
or to shut it down or any of that stuff
I mean, I'm a little older than you
but I'm also gen X.
And, you know, there is something profound being the last
generation of people who were reared in an analog world
you know, my first exposure to a computer was in college
and I typed papers on the first apple Macintosh.
And it was many years later before I sent my first email.
Like there was no internet throughout most
all of my formative years.
And you know, we're gonna,
in the same way that we would talk about our grandparents.
Like, oh, they didn't have
there was no television, no television didn't exist.
Like, there's something really profound about that.
And I think there's some wisdom
in that as we age in terms of like how we communicate
with the younger generation
and your work is infused with this idea
like there's a nostalgia to it,
but also a reverence for the practical
and what it means to roll up your sleeves
and get your hands dirty and, you know,
connect with your environment and your natural world.
You know, one of the things that like creative people
who have an audience, one of the things that they
do is they preserve the things that they found valuable.
They say to the neck, to their audience, who's invariably
gonna be younger than their influences.
They say, oh, this is important,
remember this, here's something, look at this.
And I don't know, to me, it's natural.
It's part of being very, very stubborn being like
there are certain lines that I've drawn.
Like I remember when, you know, in high school they went
from Mac to DOS-based machines
and I just, it had been Mackintosh
and I could get my head around that
and you'd click the thing around.
And you double-click,
and then dos was typing in these codes.
And I just said, no.
I never did that either.
I said, if this is going to be the thing,
I'm not doing it
and you can fail me and whatever,
but I will not do this.
Because the floppy disk that you had to put in
and the whole thing
I mean, that was fine cause Apple
had those floppy disks and so forth
but the code typing in C colon, slash
and everything had to be exactly right.
And do all this work just so it would like a zero would come
up on the screen, like, no.
Nope.
But I, think, yeah, I don't
I'm afraid of that word nostalgia
because it does sound like, I mean, it is nostalgia
but it's also like, this is just kind of how I live.
I have an old truck and I put so much energy
and love into it, but like I love driving it.
I love it.
I do.
It comes across in the videos reverence
for this truck is unparalleled.
We'll be back in a sec, but first
if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book
Voicing Change, featuring excerpts from poignant essays
by and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast, it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in all wrapped
in a hardcover coffee table form that provides a great taste
of what we do here at the RRP and serves
as a beautiful keepsake or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website
signed copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct
to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc,
that's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
I heard you talking about this in another interview.
Another relic of our era being gen X is
that we grew up in a time in which we just weren't exposed
to the truth of possibilities.
Like I remember going to, I went to a really nice college
and I was unclear on what I wanted to do.
And I went to the campus, you know, career counseling center
and it was just brochures on consulting companies
and applications for investment banks.
And I was like, is this it?
Like is this all that is available to me?
There was no, as you had mentioned
in this other interview, there was no YouTube.
You couldn't pull up videos of the people
that you revered and respected
and have them tell you exactly how they did it.
So there was this sense of these people are inaccessible.
What they're doing is not possible
for the average human being.
They were baked as geniuses from the get-go
and I'm just going to have to go, you know
pursue this sort of mundanity.
Yeah, they left, they leave out the story of the geniuses.
Right?
And so, wait, you went to Stanford.
I did, yeah
But now don't you think Stanford is kind
of the opposite right?
I mean, I was there at a transition period, you know
it was this great institution,
but it was right on the precipice of it becoming
like the tech place to be, you know,
Palo Alto at the time was still a pretty bucolic
little college town.
And of course there was Intel and IBM and things like that.
And a lot of my, you know
friends were studying computer science and the like
but there wasn't that sense of like Silicon valley.
And this is where it's all happening, that came later.
And I have lots of friends that went
off to make billions of dollars and do that.
And, you know, I just wanted to read books
and do other things like, you know I sort of wasn't
plugging into that sensibility at the time,
but yeah, I'm sure it's different now.
I mean, now it's like a giant metropolis,
it's completely different.
Did you know how much work you were going to have to do?
That was that I guess, to get into Stanford you have to do
(indistinct)
Like, that was the thing that came as,
and to this day comes a surprise to me,
is the amount of, I don't care how smart you are,
the amount of, just the crazy amount of work.
Like you know, I don't know.
That came as a surprise to me.
I didn't know it was gonna be to do something of consequence
or to do like, oh, follow your path or whatever
was going to be, I can't believe how much work it is.
And how long it takes, right.
It takes so long, even though you're doing all this work,
like every waking hour.
Yeah, well, I look at it like that.
I mean, I was never super talented in anything
that I was doing or that I continue to do.
I'm a grinder, so I'm never afraid of the hard work.
Like I relish that and I see that as my advantage long-term
like 'cause I'll outwork anybody
and bridge that talent deficit gap
to the best of my abilities,
and that's the way I looked at, you know,
that's how I got into Stanford
and that's how I tried to keep pace with these students
that were much smarter than me and talented
in ways that I couldn't possibly imagine.
But yet I think on top of that is this patience
and appreciation for the length of time that it takes
to do anything well, right.
And I look at your path,
I wanna talk about the sobriety aspect of it,
but it's been a 10 year period of you
kind of figuring out who you are and what you want to be
until you get to this point where you can synthesize
all of these experiences that you've had and deliver them
in a way that I think you're hitting a certain stride
right now in terms of what you're doing
and how you're communicating with the world.
That's a reflection of that 10 year period of work
that you've put in.
And the things that...
I'm 54 like I didn't start figuring out who I was
or what I wanted to do until I was like 41, 42 years old.
And I've spent the last nine years doing this thing
and I only feel now, like I'm starting to understand
what it is exactly.
It takes time and I think everybody particularly now
in the way that the culture is,
with this kind of hack your way to success
and you know this priority on trying to find the shortcut,
we're missing the bigger picture.
It's in that struggle, it's in that journey
that you develop the residence that will make you great
in whatever field it is that you're trying to pursue.
So you went and you did, you went to law school, right?
Yeah, I mean, that was a giant mishap, all together.
Yeah, so I grew up in Washington, DC.
I was a swimmer, went to Stanford, swam there, graduated,
lived in New York City for a couple of years,
went upstate to law school for a couple of years
but spent most of my time in Manhattan
getting into trouble and screwing up my life.
Moved to San Francisco, was a lawyer there
for a couple of years.
Moved here in '96, was a lawyer for a couple of years,
bottomed out on drugs and alcohol.
Went to treatment got sober, sobriety was my job.
I still worked as a lawyer for many years after that
but sobriety was the thing, you know,
and that was my introduction to tools and new principles
for how to organize my life and live.
And that's still the lens through which I, you know,
process everything that I do.
But that was, I mean, I got sober in '98
and I feel like only now I'm starting to really feel
like I'm expressing the authentic version of who I am.
Whoa.
Yeah, I mean, the brutality of sobriety,
(speakers talking over each other)
It is unbelievable how hard it is.
Are you comfortable talking about that?
I am, I called a friend before I did my sobriety movie
because there's the traditions.
One of the things is there's this quotation
about in something, something, something
in television and radio.
And it's like in one of the traditions.
We were anonymous at the level of press radio and film.
So it's always a tricky thing.
And as a sort of public facing person myself,
I struggle with the tension
between wanting to speak about these issues,
'cause again, it's sort of like that campus job center,
like there wasn't a lot of information.
And I think that the downside of that tradition
is that there's a lot of people who don't really understand
what's available to them when they're in pain
and struggling.
So I try to walk that tight rope and share my...
It's always experience-based, I just share my experience.
I try to steer clear of being specific
about the 12 step program itself.
But everybody has different opinions
about where that line lives.
Yeah, I mean, lucky for me, like, if you like stories,
man, that is your place that you go
and you will hear the most incredible things,
the most incredible stories.
And then when you hear someone tell your story,
that's like, that's the biggie.
That's the one where you're like, okay,
because I think people don't feel like,
they call it qualifying when you sit at the desk
and tell your story, right.
And I think a lot of people just go like,
"No, no I don't, you know, I don't drink like that guy
"in the gutter" or whatever.
And that's how I felt.
I was like, no because I'm not like, so-and-so,
I'm like, blah, blah, blah.
But like really when I sat in there, I was like,
"Okay, I gotta restructure the whole way,
"the whole way of thinking, my whole way of thinking."
And then you don't have the thing anymore,
you don't have the the valve, the valve's gone
and the valve is the meetings.
And like when you start to go (indistinct),
you just, okay drop everything and go to a meeting
and it'll be okay and that works.
COVID was like, I moved to...
I had a lot of trouble living in New York.
I lived in New York for like...
I moved in '98 and I'm still keeping an apartment there.
And in my 40s, just I never lived,
I never had enough money to like live like a New Yorker.
Like I never made enough money, never, made enough money
to like go to a Broadway show or take taxis.
If I wanted to go somewhere, I had to do the subway,
which is almost nonfunctional.
It's the worst subway system I've ever been anywhere
including like Lisbon, Portugal or Mexico city.
It's the worst subway system I've ever been on.
It's horrible.
Highly offensive to the spirited man.
It doesn't work, it doesn't work at all.
And so I rode a bicycle or walked.
So navigating around that city is very, very important.
And there's just, this is another reason why attention
to detail, because there's no margin for error.
There's no margin.
You can't leave your bike unlocked.
Never, never, not once or else it's gonna be...
It will be stolen.
And that wore on me, that really wore on me
because I don't have that.
I'm not naturally inclined to be that kind
of left-brained person who's like careful with keys
and wallets and stuff.
Thankfully New York city beat that into me
because I think you need that degree of functionality
to do things.
But that stress like really, really wore on me.
I had to go to get from my apartment to outside,
I had to go through five doorways,
five doorways to go from my room in my apartment to outside.
And one of those doorways was an elevator.
Two of those doorways were elevators.
And being stoned, I didn't mind any of it.
Right, so to bring it back, this is the introduction
to drugs and alcohol as a coping mechanism
for dealing with being flat broke in New York City
and trying to just fucking make your way.
Yeah, and the thing is like, I tried to get it
across in the video very subtly when I was like,
there's this amazing shot of me
like riding in the sunset in Maine.
And it just says sometimes it was like this
before I was sober, sometimes it was like this
riding my motorcycle in Maine.
But that's what we hang on to.
And the point I'm making is that like, it wasn't all bad.
It wasn't 100% bad.
These tools were useful at the time, they got us through,
like you got through law school.
That ain't no--
No, they work until they stop working.
That's right.
There is reason why we do it
because it's actually serving a purpose for us.
There is a functionality to it.
It is hell, when it stops working, it's horrible.
It was pot for you mostly though.
Yeah, that's what took me out in the end.
It was I couldn't function without it.
I was just full of rage.
I was horrible without it.
And yeah.
And, oh God and I quit.
Was the reckoning out here or what was the moment?
Yeah, I was in Yosemite.
I've had nothing but bad experiences in Yosemite.
Something about that place in me don't mix.
And I was in the last beer I ever drank was in Yosemite
and yeah, it was, I didn't bring any weed on me.
I had been looking forward to this trip for so long.
I've been working really hard
and I went up there and I just cracked.
I just lost all control of all my emotions
and I just called a friend of mine and he was like,
"You know what, try go into a meeting, man."
So he had been sober for a few years
and I was like, it was like a total.
I was like, whoa, like that was the last, my last suspect.
I thought I was had mental illness and all this stuff.
And it was like, "Oh, whoa, okay, really?"
It can't be the pot.
And I was like, okay.
And then I just went and it was just like...
The first one was in Atwater.
I was like, yeah...
(speakers talking over each other)
No, no, it was like in a little just nondescript room.
And man, I went back there, I went back there for like,
I was out here for a movie premiere thing
for a space program.
And I went to that meeting.
And then like I saw this girl that I kind of went out
on a date with in New York who's like kind of a...
She's a famous person, obviously I'm not gonna say her name.
And it was just like, how this is so random
but this is what this thing is.
It's just tons of these running, the people you run into.
Another thing about it is if I could just go on and on,
but in my mind, it's a magical thing.
It's something...
I don't believe in magic, but like magic is as sort of
an adjective we use to describe things
that we can't explain.
And so any kind of like people that I run into,
that's important.
Like if I run into someone from the past,
that one of them, that means something,
there's something to that.
That's not just some random thing.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, 100%, I mean, I, I believe in the magic of AA
like no other, I mean my life,
it just it bears zero resemblance
to what it was like before now.
And it's purely a result of doing the thing
the way that they tell you to do it.
But the people and I think there's something really special
about the recovery community in Los Angeles.
The people are unbelievable.
I've met so many incredible human beings
that are so important to me now
that are the most meaningful people in my life.
And just where else, I mean, on that subject of magic,
like just generally what other institution exists
or you could walk into a room utterly broken, alone,
lost, desperate, broke and be embraced by a group of people
who truly want nothing from you other than to just help you
and support you.
And the only requirement is that you have a desire.
You can go in drunk and high,
you just have to have a desire to stop.
And when you start to get it, your only obligation
is you start paying it forward to other people.
But do you have to bring a dollar,
bring a dollar, bring a $1 bill.
But if you don't have a dollar, ain't nothing but a thing,
you have to have a dollar.
You might feel weird if you're like,
"Man, no one told me to bring (indistinct)."
I mean, I just, I think it's one of the most miraculous
things of modern times that it hasn't imploded either.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's unbelievable, it's unbelievably miraculous.
And I also love the like...
I love the like secret handshake thing about it too,
like that you meet people out in the wild
like, it'll help you, like it'll help you.
And if you're in a new town, you can just pop in
and then you're instantly dialed into some...
You're instantly dialed into a community.
So I ran into an old friend in New York at a meeting
and he had been sober for awhile.
And we started going to this one meeting on Sundays
in the East Village, I can't remember the name of it now.
It was one of those big, like, not stadium,
but like the size of a big venue meeting
like it was in a playhouse or something.
And so they would do, 'cause it was once a week,
they would do like anniversary, like anyone with five years
and then there'd be a big line of people that would come up.
And this friend of mine pointed out, he said,
"Now watch between five years and 10 years,
"watch how few people go up."
So the person at the front, the meeting chair would be like,
"Okay, anybody with six years of sobriety."
And then like 11 people would come up.
Anyone with eight years of sobriety
and like three people would come up.
Anybody with one year of sobriety, line 40 people.
And he said, there's a...
He's like, "I went through it too and there's a trough
"between five and 10 years where you stop engaging."
And I'm at the very...
I'm doing that.
I'm like, 'cause COVID is year eight for me,
2020 would be your eight for me.
So I'll be nine in September, God willing.
And I didn't do any of those Zoom meetings.
My last meeting was in a church in Topanga
and I'm really, I'm paying a price.
I mean, I'm really crazy.
It's been hard, the Zoom thing's been rough.
There are some great Zoom meetings,
but my meeting attendance, precipitously dropped off.
Like I really struggle with trying to stay connected
in that way.
And how did it manifest?
Just all my character defects coming out
and me just being generally not happy, you know.
That's one and the same boat.
Yeah, and, and I'll tell you this
and then we can kind of move off of this a little bit.
At 13 years, I went out for like a day and a half.
Oh, no.
I came right back, but I had to reset the whole deal.
It was the most humiliating, embarrassing
and kind of pathetic.
It was a super lame relapse
but the good news is I came right back.
And that was a reflection of what you just spoke about that
like lackadaisical attitude towards sobriety
that for a lot of people just becomes a thing
after you've accumulated a number of years.
And I just found that I never questioned
whether I was an alcoholic and I didn't stop going to meet,
I still went to meetings, I went to meetings.
I mean, when I was newly sober,
I was going to two a day for a long time.
I went less and I got really interested
in these other things that I was doing.
And what I didn't realize is how much I'd made them
my higher power and how I started to think I didn't need,
like, I've been doing this for a while.
Like I get it, it's cool, I'll check in.
And when I did check in and show up at the meetings,
there was an ego to it 'cause it's like,
"I've been around here, I know what's up.
"You come to me for the answer.
"I can give the share that people wanna hear."
And that's just, you know, you're toast.
Yeah.
So it was a reckoning and a reset that really helped me
appreciate just how fundamentally important it is
to make it the first thing
even though I'm still been struggling
with the Zoom thing and all of that
and really helped me understand like this is just
something that I have to do.
It's the progress.
It's like the top priority that's like the number one thing.
But we forget, we wake up everyday and we forget.
I forgot until you said, until you just said,
I was making other things my higher power that hit me like,
I was like, "Oh, my God, I've been doing it."
So this is an interesting moment for you
because the spirit of man is blowing up.
You're getting all this attention, all these subscribers,
a lot of people are interested in what you're doing
and they wanna talk to you.
And as somebody who's been pursuing this art form
relatively anonymously ever since the Neistat brothers,
I would say that you gotta make sure that you keep your ego
in check and remember what your priorities are
so that you don't get derailed by it.
Yeah, I mean, on my way over here,
I was just like, I was like,
"Okay, you are not going to therapy right now.
"Do not go in there and unload your shit on this guy.
"That's not what..."
No, this is the stuff, man.
We can go through the chronology of all of that.
My last therapist was over here in Agoura Hills.
I was just like, "Wait a minute, where am I going?"
Yeah, but none of that stuff is as good
as the meetings though.
And I haven't found any that have been as good
as the meetings.
But yeah, the ego thing, I mean it's so...
I just feel so overwhelmed with work and I cannot...
I can barely, barely keep up with it
because I didn't realize the vitality
of doing two videos a week.
I didn't realize--
I can't do two podcasts a week.
One a week is what I thought I might be able to do
because the first six that I launched my...
I launched my a Kickstarter campaign, I made six.
You spent a year making those.
That's right.
I spent a year, but it wasn't my full-time job
because I had to have a full-time job
to support making them.
And then I had a kid, a little kid that I had to watch.
And I thought, my bet was that, "Okay, if I am doing this
"full time and I'm not having to do all these other jobs
"for money, then I can do one a week."
And it was just a hunch that I could do it.
And then I called my brother like a day before
I was going to launch the Kickstarter.
And he was like, "Can you postpone it
"'cause you gotta launch the Kickstarter
"at the same time you launched the channel."
And then he said, "And you got to do two a week."
And in my head I was just like, "Okay, well I've got six,
"that's three weeks, it took me a year to make them."
You had to do 104 this year.
And then..
That was one of the first 'cause the quality is so high.
When you first launched, I watched a couple of them
and I was like, "How is this guy gonna maintain this pace
"even at one a week?"
But there's some that I throw in that I'm like,
"I can do this in one day." But it's hard, I don't know.
There's only one person on this planet who could do
what my brother did, that 800 and 800 days straight.
That's it, I know that kid, no one else could do it.
No one else can do that.
I don't think people appreciate
what an unbelievable feat that was.
He's an iron man, he's done the army.
He's summited Aconcagua, he's summited with a steel femur.
He summited Kilimanjaro.
This kid has, and he's smarter than everybody.
So he's got the two things you need.
He's got conscientiousness and intelligence
and him a 100% can do it.
Yeah, nobody else.
And been making films since, he was 17 years old.
And it almost broke him.
Yeah, and he could barely do it.
But you look at some, like I haven't watched them all
of course, 'cause there's so many.
I've only seen very few because he is so influential,
like I'll subconsciously just steal.
I'll take one of his ideas, I'll think it's one of mine
and then I'll go and do it.
Well, part of your magic sauce is that you're uncorrupted
by being a consumer of this type of content.
You've been doing your own thing.
You're not on social media and you're just,
you're living your life and you're pursuing your art
in your own way.
And that freshness that you've brought
to the work that you're doing
I think is a big reason why it's connecting with people
because it is so, I mean, you could see details
and elements that trace back to the Neistat brothers
and a little bit of overlap stylistically with your brother.
But overall, like this is completely unique and different.
And I think that's why people are embracing it
and really appreciating it.
So yeah, you should stay away from watching other stuff.
Well, I hope that's true, but in my mind,
I'm just like, I'm just ripping off this person
and this person.
But like these are the people that nobody
or very few people know about that--
Yeah, you're ripping off rendezvous from 1962 or whatever.
For sure, that's true.
Yes, that's right.
But so it's just coming from a different source.
And what was nerve wracking about...
Another thing about YouTube is there's like guts involved
in it because you're not getting paid.
You're only getting paid based on your appeal
and your appeal is measured in numbers.
It's not like eight people got tattoos of your thing
because they love it so much.
It doesn't matter, you're not gonna make a living
off of that.
And so these things cost money and they cost time.
And if you're gonna just put them up there,
you're taking this risk of like
there not gonna be enough people for me to make a living.
And then I've shown my hand so that I can't go out to Fox
or Netflix or Hulu or whatever and get the deal
because they're gonna say look at this thing
and then there's, but, but, but two things.
YouTube right now I think is approaching
this incredible golden age, so that's the first thing.
And the second thing is people are coming
from the mainstream stuff are coming into this,
are coming into this YouTube thing.
And so there's this, do you know this comedian
named Andrew Schultz?
Oh, he's so great and he was talking about during COVID
how he had this podcast set up and it was like a living room
and all this stuff.
And then he said during COVID Jimmy Kimmel
and the other Jimmy guy that does the late night thing.
Jimmy Fallon.
Jimmy Fallon, that's right.
They had to do like what he was doing.
And he's like, "Oh, it's a home game now."
Yeah, that's exactly.
I went through that same thing.
I'm like also when everybody started doing Zoom
and I was like, "Oh we're just all making videos
"of Zoom calls now, that's what we're doing."
Like, that's not the game that I signed up for,
like, I don't wanna play that game.
I'm happy to go toe to toe in the one-on-one
conversation thing.
But if we're all just doing Zoom calls and putting them up
on YouTube and in podcasts, like it's phone calls, you know,
I'm like, "I need to sit across from the person."
I'd rather not do it at all.
And I did a bunch of Zooms, but it's just not the thing.
But I think what you're saying is correct.
I think YouTube is at this point of maturation,
this inflection point where mainstream culture
has intersected with this, like, I hate that word,
like influencer culture or whatever,
where the powers that be have to reckon with it
in a way that they kind of dismissed it previously.
And I think that's different
and maybe that's only happening now, like in the past year.
But it is true, like the stakes are high for you.
If you do it in and the numbers are low,
then how does that impact your long-term career prospects
for other projects like, "Oh, people didn't like
"the thing that he did" and they can see the numbers.
It's completely transparent, but luckily it's working.
And thank God it's working, thank God it's working.
Do you ever listen to Jordan Peterson or any of his things?
I've listened to some of his stuff, yeah.
He has really great, like simple insights that have
kind of like profound implications.
And one of those insights is he talks
about the sensationalism of the news media now.
And part of it is because of it's so much cheaper
and more profitable to have just someone spouting opinions
than it is to have a team out in, I don't know, Bosnia
reporting and satellite trucks and so forth.
And that YouTube and the internet is totally destroying
that system because that system is so incredibly expensive
to maintain that they have to, in order to compete
on the profit side of things with all of their overhead,
they have to just go for what sells the most
and what sells the most is anger and disgust.
And so that's what they're trying,
that's what these opinion-based news shows
that get the ratings, that's what they're doing.
And so it's a symptom of their death now.
And whereas people are going to YouTube,
the talent is going to YouTube and people who are mature
and people who are new and like, I'm astonished
that I'm able to have this popularity with this.
I mean, basically I'm just stealing Eastern European
filmmaking techniques.
Very quiet, lots of fully sound, very slow,
it's not hyper cut.
I was really nervous.
I was like, are people just gonna like click the channel
and be like, "This is too boring."
My stuff is not driven with music.
It's more driven by sound and sometimes music
will kind of help you along a little bit.
But it was really astonishing
because there were some comments, I don't read the comments,
I take Joe Rogan's advice, I don't read the comments,
but I have Isabelle read me comments that she thinks
I might find encouraging.
And it was amazing to read that people were like expressly
being grateful for these things
I was a little bit insecure about.
They're like, "Oh, I like that it's quiet,
"I like that it's slow cut."
And I think that there've been some like copy cats,
like people who've made their own
like spirit of man things, which is unbelievably.
That's the whole point, the whole point.
And I think the thing all came, I think Isabelle
just asked me one day I was like super stressed out.
This was a couple of years ago.
And she said, "Well, if you could do anything
"and money was no object, what would you do?"
And I was like, "I would just walk around the house
"tinkering and fixing stuff and putting up coat hooks
"and making these."
And then I'd just points to stuff around the room.
"I'd be making this, I'd be making that"
because my house was just full of little.
And I did a movie called D...
I did a episode called Details that was about that tendency.
And I get to do that now without having to worry about like,
"Dude, you gotta pay that mortgage,
"you gotta pay that mortgage" as long as I'm shooting it.
As long as I'm shooting it and as long as--
Which is the other thing that you love doing anyway.
Not really.
No, really?
I hate that part.
I hate the cameras, I hate the them.
I hate the computers.
Do you like the editing?
I like the editing, I do like the editing.
Yeah, I do like it.
And my favorite part of the process is grading,
color grading.
Like I think people call it color correction
but I think that's a different thing.
But my brother, bless him, gave me like...
My brother's hand-me-down equipment
is like professional grade like whoa.
He gave me this camera, it's a Canon 1DX
unbelievably cool thing.
But his Sony alphas are like state of the art cutting edge,
the best ones and that's what he shoots on.
But he gave me this big Sony and I did...
Yesterday, I started to kind of start to love them again.
I've been using the same camera, that Canon T2
I've been using for 11 years and the one Casey gave me
as a present for my birthday.
But now I'm graduated and I didn't make any big deal,
I didn't even announce it.
But for one of these most recent videos,
I don't even remember which one it was.
I just switched over to 4K, so now everything's in 4K.
Well, the shooting, the editing, the making of the videos
is the price that you have to pay
to do the tinkering that you love, right?
Like that's the rent.
That's right.
And that's not so bad.
I like the writing, but if that--
The writing's great.
If that was all it was, I would hate it.
The writing is amazing.
That's where your true voice comes out.
Like the intentionality that you put into the monologues
is exceptional and I think that's a huge differentiator
in what you're doing because it demonstrates
the level of thought that you put into this.
Like there's a reason why I'm telling you this story
and you see the arc over the period of time on the details.
That's the one that ends with Isabel saying,
that's what I love about you.
It's like it's a very emotionally resonant moment.
Yeah.
Okay so for Christmas, and I think it was 2019.
So I had it for a year,
Isabelle got me the masterclass suite
so I could watch all of them.
And what I would do is I just put the headphones in
'cause I'm always tinkering.
And the headphones and listening to smart people talking,
for me is riddling.
Like that stops my mind from racing, I can really dial in.
It's like what pot used to do for me.
I can really dial into what I think, it relaxes me
and really help me.
Like I listened to your podcast the other day
while I was doing my most recent movie.
I listened to your podcast with Brogan.
Oh, Brogan Graham, yeah.
Yep, and then there was another one about periodicalizing
your life period.
Periodizing your life.
Okay, so I listened to the David Mamet Masterclass
and he said, I've listened to all the writers masterclasses.
And they all kind of say the same thing.
And it's, you've gotta sit in that chair
and it's you got no idea.
And then when you do have the idea,
you have no idea where it came from.
It didn't come from you, it's something that came to you
because you put the three hours in
or however many hours in, it came to you.
And the language that Mamet put it in was he said
the character in the movie goes...
If the writer didn't go through what the character
went through, it won't resonate, it won't be good.
And so when you have these surprise, it's the irony.
It's where like inevitability meets surprise,
it's because the author, the person writing that thing.
I just made a movie.
Today I finished a film that's called Breakthrough
and it's about that.
It's about that point that you get to
where you need the breakthrough.
And that's the point, every time
and I've done over 1000 of these short films.
Every time you're just like, I quit, this is it for me.
This is it, I could be a diesel mechanic.
This doesn't happen when you're working on a diesel engine
but it does happen when you're working on a diesel.
And so if you've been doing it for years and years
and years, and you've been making these things
and you're starting to get conscious of these things,
one, you can get more of them more quickly.
You can get these breakthroughs more quickly
but you have to sit in the chair and also you recognize them
and you feel them coming.
It's very hard to articulate--
(speakers talking over each other)
Also you develop a trust and a confidence
that you will have that breakthrough
because it's happened so many times prior.
That's right.
Even when you're experiencing it, you're like,
"I know, yeah, I'm feeling it again
"but I just have to keep going."
And then once again, just when you thought
it was never gonna work out, you figure it out.
That's right.
And the video that I finished today,
when do you think this will come out?
I don't know, not for a little bit.
Okay, good so then it won't 'cause this video I did
will probably be out by the time this is out.
So I do this thing where I say, like you hit the wall,
you hit the wall with your project.
And I say this, I say thousands, thousands of walls.
Every project has this wall since day one.
And then it cuts abruptly, the music cuts out everything.
Hammer cuts too many DV footage, New York city shaky camera.
And it says day one May 1st, 2000.
And then that wall that's May 1st, that wall,
the breakthrough is November 17th.
Now the breakthrough that I needed to make this movie
that you're watching, I had two days
to get that breakthrough and I did it.
And so to your point is that they come faster
and you get accustomed and you understand that.
But I think David Mamet articulating that for me
and listening to it.
And all of the writers saying that,
Judy Bloom says that same thing.
And that's what you're seeing when you see a good piece
of writing is you're seeing the struggle
that this guy learned that this guy didn't know that
going in or this gal didn't know that
going into writing this thing.
And that's what you're seeing.
I don't know--
It's such a relief to hear that coming from David Mamet
because you just think this guy is gifted in a way
that I can't connect with.
But if he's talking about this struggle,
there's a sense of comfort that can come over you
when it's visited upon you
and just to hear him say it, right?
Isn't it incredible how many people are doing this stuff
and how...
By this stuff, I mean, podcasts and making things
and putting them out for everybody and how good it all is.
Not all of it, but how much of it is good.
Do you ever listen to Sean Avery's podcast?
No, who's that?
I was on that.
He was an instigator on the New York Rangers.
So he was a hockey player, but he was like...
I asked him if he was an enforcer and he said,
"No, no, no, I was..."
I think he said an instigator, I can't remember,
but he was like a tough guy
and I've known him for a dozen years or something.
And he does this podcast called "No Graffs Given"
and he's an NHL hockey player.
He's just got it, it's like really interesting.
I think this is like the first cup podcast I did.
Oh, cool.
And he's just got it.
Super cool, but there you go.
So many podcasts, I know.
And so many who's been doing this for a long time,
I'm like, "I don't know--
When did you start?
2012, end of 2012.
Wow.
Yeah.
How many have you done?
605 or something like that.
Yeah, yeah.
But I mean, when I started, it wasn't cool.
It was for radio shack tinkerers.
It wasn't a career path, it certainly wasn't cool
or the thing that people were clamoring to do.
So, why did you do it?
Because I love the media myself.
Like I was listening to Marin and Rogan and Corolla.
And at the time it was mostly comedians.
They were the ones who were doing it
and they would have their friends on.
So although I was an early adopter very much so,
I wasn't the first.
Kevin Smith was an early pioneer and I just loved
the medium, but you had to work for it,
like you had to go on your desktop computer,
figure out what you wanted to listen to, download the MP3,
bounce it to an iPod.
You had to know you had to be very intentional
and committed in order to be a listener.
But I was just curating my whole listening experience
way back in 2010, 2009 and was flabbergasted
that nobody else I knew was doing this.
And I just thought, this is unbelievable.
The amount of information that's available,
I can listen to these incredible conversations
with the same thing that you're talking about,
like people would come in and share their journey.
Here's how I did the thing that I did and it's free,
and nobody I know is doing it.
It's like hours long, like an hour with Rob Williams.
Yeah, I know, exactly, right?
Mark Marin was the one that did when I started listening
in 2012, 2011 and I was just like, "This is un..."
Before that you did not, unless it was a documentary film.
You never ever gonna hear anybody talk
for more than five minutes about anything in media.
Never.
I mean, sometimes that may be on Howard Stern.
Sure, even those were segments.
Those guys couldn't--
A name is Charlie Rose.
Yeah, okay, sure, 30 minutes.
So at the same time, it was when I was getting
into like all this ultra endurance stuff that I was doing.
So I was spending an unbelievable amount of time
by myself on a bike or running on a trail
and I would bring podcasts with me to accompany.
So I would listen to hours and hours.
And so my 10,000 hours was first as a listener
and then I had a book that came out in 2012
and then I started thinking about what I wanted to do next.
And it was just a whimsical like,
"Hey, we have some mics."
Like just my wife and I had a conversation.
There was no plant, like I'm launching a show.
It was just, that was fun, like, let's do it tomorrow.
It started like that and it's just built from there.
But it was very uncrowded at that time.
So, you could go right to the top of the iTunes charts
because nobody was starting podcasts.
YeaH, it was like digital video in 2001.
And there was no, like in the topics that I was interested
in exploring, there wasn't anybody doing anything
all that compelling.
There was tons of comedians and there was news
and stuff like that.
But talking about kind of self-improvement
or entrepreneurship or health and wellness, fitness,
stuff like that, like nobody was really doing anything
all that interesting.
And I just thought, I know some cool people,
like I've learned a few things, like let's just do this
and it's just grown organically.
Aren't you so appreciative of that 10,000 hours discovery
that someone, I know Malcolm Gladwell gets the credit.
It wasn't him.
No, it wasn't him, it wasn't him.
But whatever.
Okay, so we all read--
I forget his name, but it--
Was it outliers?
It was in outliers.
The theory comes from this research psychologist
who I think just passed away.
His name escapes me right now.
And that theory has been put to the test.
There's a book called "Range" by a guy called David Epstein.
I read it.
Yeah, he he's been on the podcast too.
So him and Malcolm have these like little teta tats
over that stuff.
Yeah, I watched also like a symposium of those two guys
on stage talking.
They're funny together.
Since you brought up the 10,000 hours thing,
it's like I got the 10,000 hours editing
pretty seven years probably.
And then just recently, so I'm 20 years and now doing this
making every day, making these things, some form of it,
either shooting, writing, or editing, 20 years of it.
And then there's the craft stuff
of like kind of the subject matter or if I need anything,
I have to make it myself for the thing.
And recently I tried to like...
I'm working with this guy who's new
and I'm trying to like...
I'm just like, "Okay just shoot this."
And then I have to like, really explain that dah, dah, dah
and then it's occurred to me.
And I said, you got 10,000 hours of camera now
'cause it's been 20 years, you've got 10,000 hours
of camera.
There's camera stuff that you don't know you know.
And that comes as a surprise when you realize,
"Oh no, no, no, no, it's not just one thing,
"you might have"--
You don't know how much you know.
You've forgotten more than most people have learned.
But you have people helping you.
Like when you're making, there's somebody else
holding the camera and a bunch of this stuff.
Yep, there's BC Slate who's...
It's just him and me really and then Isabelle.
He's the guy from the catch video.
Yeah, yeah.
Then there's Isabel who I just make do stuff.
Like if the kid is asleep or something.
Who'd you get to get up at five o'clock in the morning
and go running with you?
BC, yeah, he was on a bicycle.
He was on an electric bicycle because a bicycle,
the pumping, you would see the pumping.
The camera wouldn't be a smooth shot
but the electric bicycle you can just write real perfectly.
And then those GoPros are really incredible.
We mounted it to the thing.
Like listening to you guys about the endurance stuff,
I'm like, yes, I am impressed, but it's, how can you do it?
How do you do it?
How do you, like the amount of time,
the number of hours a day.
How many hours a day do you put into it?
I mean, now it's at a super low boil.
I mean, I haven't raced in many years
and my life was a lot simpler
when I was really doing it hardcore.
Like, and that was a spiritual journey that I was on
trying to figure out what I wanted to do with my life.
And the training was really a template
for exploring myself, I think.
But I was in a lot of pain and had a lot of confusion
and I have a capacity for that kind of thing
and I enjoy doing it.
So I don't dread it, I actually look forward to it.
It's like the highlight of my day.
But it's just like, anything else.
Like when I watched one of your movies, I'm like,
"How the hell does that guy do that?"
Oh, good, thank God.
I would never be able to...
Yeah, I don't understand,
like how is he putting the camera there?
Like that just seems like it would...
That would take me months to figure it out.
So the endurance stuff, you just, you're out
and you run four miles every day.
So next week you're running four and a half miles,
a week after that you're running five and a half miles
and time becomes malleable, like what's hard and what's easy
changes and what you get used to--
I know all that, but like the motivate to keep it,
it just, it takes so long.
It's not like running--
Look at what you do, just replace endurance
for filmmaking.
Look at how hard you've worked for how long.
And a lot of people would look at your path and say like,
"Why are you still doing this?"
'Cause it's there though.
But the thing I'm doing is there, it's like still there.
You can go watch the Holland tunnel right now,
but your thing, it's gone.
Does that make it any less real or meaningful because--
Also I have to do it 'cause I need to pay...
There's no other way for me to make money.
I'm not going to Stanford, I'm like--
Well, forget about all of that.
Like the endurance stuff, there was no way
I was getting paid for that.
Who would've known that it would have ever led to anything
beyond the simple doing of it.
Yeah.
No, you're not going--
But when you're compelled.
That's what I mean.
When you're compelled--
There's even less motivation.
In some ways, it was my version of being the spirited man
in my own way.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
I'm understanding something new here.
Walk me back to, I'm really interested in curious
about the decisions that you've made
after the Neistat brothers was canceled.
So walking up to that moment,
you and your brother get together.
I grew up with Tom Scott, I don't know if you knew that.
I've known Tom since we were 14, we were in school.
Unbelievable, that guy.
So I first knew who you guys were
because Tom was like, "You should check these guys out."
Wow.
So I was on that.
Oh, and I brought these too.
I actually have, I've got DVDs.
Wow, I have two left.
Casey gave me these.
Oh yeah, 2000.
He dated it, of course, 2012.
Gave me that, and then give me another one in 2013.
Wow.
I've got the pen from his studio.
So yeah, I've been like hip to your guys' vibe
for a long time.
The Neistat brothers thing happens, you guys are on HBO.
It kinda was a thing where like nobody
really watched it though.
Yeah, it was on at midnight on Fridays.
It didn't get picked up.
Casey decides to go and do what we all kind of know he did
and you make this decision to go in a different direction.
I think there were a lot of people out there who were like,
"Did they have a fight?"
Like "What happened?"
Like "Why is he going over here?
"Why didn't he continue to make movies with Casey?"
What was that about and what was your mindset at the time?
So I thought I had...
Okay, first of all, I was on drugs and drunk all the time.
So I was a completely unhinged ego maniacal nightmare
because I from scratch from a video camera
that was the first thing I ever bought on eBay,
I got an HBO show with my brother who turns out
is like a genius.
And so I started not...
I just wanna blame it on drugs and alcohol,
but you know, it's not fair, it's just...
But if you were--
I have been through what I'd been through.
You were asked at the time, I'm sure people were like,
"Why aren't you still doing this?"
Or what would you have said in that moment?
You know, Casey sat me down and he said, "Look,"
and at the time you got to remember, okay, what is this?
He's got like a 12 year old kid.
And he said, "I have to prioritize money in my life,
"I have to make a lot of money."
I got a kid he's going to be in college soon"
whatever and we all have to do that.
And I thought we were on this path that would continue
and we would just keep doing the thing that we were doing
which was not really understanding what we were doing
but following these little impulses
and turning it into this really successful thing.
And what I didn't realize at the time
was how much work Casey was doing
on the business side of things,
how many meetings he was taking,
how many things he was writing up,
all the numbers and things and all this stuff.
I just thought that we were these two super talented
Bohemian dudes and everything was just working out for us
'cause I wasn't doing any of that stuff.
And so he put together some work for us to do
like some jobs that he and Tom went out and got.
And I was just like, "No, I'm not doing that.
"Let's fucking keep doing what we did with the thing."
And it was just like, you know, we got to keep...
This studio costs a lot of money to support
and blah, blah, blah.
And so I was just like, "Well, okay, fine.
"Then I won't be a part of the studio anymore.
"I'll just pack up and I'll move out to Los Angeles"
because that was what I wanted to do.
New York was really, like I said before,
it was just like really grinding on me
and that's what I did.
And then when we didn't get a second season of the TV show,
it was just like, "Okay, keep going."
And I had that arrogance to just keep going
and keep going and keep going.
And I've heard this story so many times.
There's this guy, I can't remember his last name.
It seems like, I think Wayne White,
the guy who he does the paintings.
Oh, the cartoonist who's a musician?
Pee-wee's Playhouse?
Yes, they made the documentary about him.
Yes, called "Beauty is Embarrassing."
And his story is very similar to mine
and it's just like grinding yourself to the bone
until it's just like, "No, this isn't right."
So I came out to LA and I thought the whole thing
was like, make feature films.
Learn this whole thing of making these.
I didn't realize we were pioneering anything.
I thought we were just in the minor leagues
trying to get the bigs, the guide the...
What's the guy from the Brooklyn Dodgers who signed kids
the greatest name, the guy who signed Jackie Robinson?
Branch Rickey, Branch Ricky is gonna come down and sign us
and we're gonna get the thing.
But you can't be blamed for having that idea,
I mean, that was the idea of the time.
I mean, Casey went through that as well
with producing that Safdie brothers movie
and have that experience.
And I know those guys are part of your,
like sort of creative collective.
That was the path.
People forget when the Neistat brothers came out,
there was no YouTube.
And you were making viral videos
before there was even a means for something to go viral.
The pipes, there was no distribution channel at the time.
So how would one know that this was this impending future
that would create a career path.
You have to ask Casey Neistat 'cause he knew.
Yeah, only somebody like Casey.
And so the way I think about this
and tell me if this is fair or way off base,
like certainly both of you guys are our artists.
I think the differentiator is there's a little bit more
of purity in terms of how you think about art
and creativity.
Whereas Casey is this entrepreneur business person
who's figured out this perfect combination
of art and commerce at just the exact correct
cultural moment for him to ignite a wildfire.
When I, over many years of knowing Casey,
what gets overlooked in terms of how people think about him
is the fact that he's a fucking genius
when it comes to marketing and business.
Like he understands that side of things
in a way that very few people do.
And he's able to cast that sensibility with great foresight.
Like he knows what's coming,
he understands what's important and what's not.
And he melds that with an expertise in storytelling,
like his vlogs, it's not just that he made 800 movies
in a row, like they're all really good
and they all have three act structure
and they're extraordinarily well edited
and conceptually coherent in their own regard.
Like that's a feat that I don't know
that anybody else on earth could have accomplished.
And so I don't think that yes, people love his videos
but I don't think they understand why they love them
and why they're so good and what makes them work.
And it's that engine behind the scenes that fuels
that whole thing from that very specific sensibility
that he has.
But when I look at you, I see somebody who thought,
"You know, I'm an artist, I'm gonna continue
"to be this Bohemian guy and I'll figure it out as I go."
I think in the end, we do different emotions,
like Casey does exuberance and comedy, he's hilarious.
And I do, I don't know introspection,
and I don't know, insight or something, I don't know.
I think that's correct, yeah.
The combination--
Comedy and fun is way more fun than--
Well, that's gonna travel on the internet.
You know what I mean?
But as far as like, I mean what he's done
and trying to do this thing, like what he's done
is a really significant artistic feat.
And I know that we have friends that say that stuff too,
our close friends.
We have allies, old old friends, like from the neighborhood
and stuff that like this was my old friend
and he says what you just said to me, he says that to me.
And then Casey has his old friends
and they say whatever they say to him
and Casey has the success and the thing.
But the way I look at it, it doesn't feel like I'm an artist
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
It feels like I can't do it any other way.
It's not that it's like, okay, fine, put Michael Jordan
behind the wheel of Lewis Hamilton's Mercedes.
He's not gonna do it.
I don't care how good Michael Jordan is.
He's not gonna get it around the track as fast
as Lewis Hamilton.
And that's really what it feels like.
And it's like, maybe because I worked with Sachs
and his instruction, he is an incredibly good teacher.
And one of the things he taught you,
he taught people who listened was the...
Okay, we're writing a studio manual, Sachs and I
for his studio and one of the chapters is called,
"Pretension, How to Avoid It and How to Exploit It."
So he went--
Sound like a human resources manual.
Part that, it's a lot that.
But there's this thing where...
There's a problem with art and with filmmaking
and with acting, and the problem with it is that it's cool
and it's perceived as cool.
And that's a problem because sometimes it's cool, sure.
But that's not what it is, you know what I mean?
It's a job, you don't go into it because it's cool.
And a lot of people do go into it because it's cool.
And when you say, "Oh, I do it because I'm an artist
"and I wanna do it this way."
Like that sounds cool, but that's not really,
that's not what it feels like.
I just feel like I didn't prioritize.
I'm always hoping people will say, will ask me
what's the worst advice you've ever gotten.
And to me, the worst advice I've ever gotten, I think
is do what you love and the money will come automatically.
That is fucking preposterous.
I wasted 15 years doing that and it's not the fuck true.
Like you really have to put...
Everyone needs money.
Everyone needs to have money unless you're born with it
and you still need it.
You really have to prioritize and understand
that making money is a skill and is a craft.
That's not automatic, it's very intentional
and you have to go after and do it.
Casey learned that at 16
when he got his girlfriend pregnant.
I was there, man, I was there--
When he left home and moved in with you, right?
Yes, I remember that whole thing coming--
That had to be insane.
What was going on with you when he--
I was just like, I mean yeah, I mean, it was like.
(speakers talking over each other)
And lived with you when you were in college, right?
Rich, he was so at ease with it.
He was just like, "Yeah."
He was like, "So yeah, I'm gonna have a baby."
I'm like, "You're 16 years old right now."
Like, "Are you kidding me?"
And then like, I can't, I mean, I can't believe.
Okay, so on top of all that, he's a dad.
On top of all that stuff he did, he's also a dad
and he's like a high school dropout.
And so I just think that, I mean I don't know,
it's not intentional, I wish I had made more money.
I wish I had, I would have been...
I think what he did is more pure than what I did
because he just unconsciously did it
and look at how much work he has, you know?
Sure, but then he had to take out
an entire year and a half off.
Oh, if I could do that, I'd never make another video.
That's interesting that you say that
because we just got off this jag of you talking
about the disconnect between the romantic ideal
of the artist, the person who thinks it's cool
to be an artist.
You look at Tom Sachs and you're wow, like huge, cool lofts
and like lots of cool stuff.
It's like, it's sexy.
But the artist is the person who creates
because there is no other choice.
There is something inside that person
that is yearning to be expressed.
It's a specific lens on an experience or an event
that in the expression says something more broadly
about humanity or the world that we live in.
And that person cannot rest until that exists in the world.
And so when I talk about purity,
like I sense that in yourself.
So it's interesting that you would say you would never make
another video again, like, I don't believe you,
I don't think that's true.
That's what it feels like, it feels like it.
I heard David Spade once say, "If I had my brother's money,"
his brother is Andy Spade, he's a friend of mine.
I said, "If I have my brother's money, I'd throw mine away."
That's funny.
I don't know, I just...
Oh wow, the work is really, it's very hard.
And I made a video or an episode called "Gratitude"
because it is so rare and so...
It is an incredible blessing to be able to make a living
out of the things that you make with your hands.
Another thing that came to me as a great relief
is I heard Jordan Peterson talking.
He's advising kids in college and he was talking
about how impossible it is to be a professional artist.
And he just goes one after another, after another,
after another and these are rational, rational,
correct reasons.
And hearing him say that and then knowing...
I've never really been able to pay all my bills
but I'm still doing it for 20 years.
I've been doing this thing
and I do have a tremendous amount of gratitude for it.
And at the same time, I'm wrestling with the resentment
of the reality of how hard it is.
And I just wish I would just lie and just say,
"Oh no, it's unbelievable, I wake up, I pop out of bed.
"It's unbelievable."
But really, and I hope that this is just a phase
and maybe when I get older it'll ease back.
But it it's as if I'm in a house that's on fire
and I have to just grab all the passports and the thing
and the kid and the star and try to put some of it out.
And it just feels like a terror and a panic all the time.
Oh man.
Yeah, there are sustainability concerns
with what you're doing, in terms of your overall wellbeing.
Yeah, I'm trying to develop these families of videos
that I can make in one day.
And I've had some success it's a hard day
but I've had some success of doing these videos
that take one day, like the one about the lock
in the Tacoma that wouldn't lock.
And then the one about the bike rack and the Tacoma,
those took one day and I'm trying to develop a family.
And I came up with another one,
that's the one day thing yesterday
that I'm gonna try to make tomorrow.
And those saved me 'cause they give me more time
to work on the longer ones.
And then I also don't know how much a business
you're supposed to talk about but maybe this isn't business.
But I also want to be able to dedicate more time
to brand sponsored things.
So like, if a brand is paying me a bunch of money
to do an episode, I wanna be able to do six of the days
of that week or five of the days of that week on that video
which is what I just completed today
with this breakthrough movie.
And today was satisfying finishing that movie.
Can I just tell one technical thing?
I just wanna say, I just wanna tell you.
So, I had to make a wall that broke,
that snapped and broke away.
And I was like, "Oh, you can't make it out a cardboard
"'cause cardboard doesn't snap, it bends.
"Can't make it out of paper, paper bends and tears
"a little bit, it doesn't bang snap."
So, this is the best thing that happened on this movie
is I figured out...
Oh, and the thing that needed to break this wall
were little puzzle pieces.
They needed to shatter the wall.
And so I figured out how to make a wall
by taking an angle grinder and putting a sanding pad on it
and then sanding the paper off of sheet rock
off of both sides and then carving the little bricks
with a dremmel with the rode, with the dzzz, dzzz
and you can draw with it and I drew this perfect wall
and it was so amazing.
I had one take, it took an hour to make this thing.
And I had to pull a puzzle piece through a string
with a string through this, through a hole in the wall.
And it's super, super close up, super close up.
And that like a puzzle piece is almost full screen
and it just snapped the wall and I shot it in slow motion.
The sound was perfect.
And that's satisfying.
Right.
That's wonderful.
So this is why--
One of the 100,000 things--
But that's why you're never gonna stop
making videos though, right?
Like the exuberance and the enthusiasm
with which you just shared that story.
Like you're toast, dude 'cause you're all in.
But it's the pace, Rich, how do I get around the pace?
I don't know man, talk to your brother about that.
I don't know what to do about it.
My brother said you suck it up.
Do you really have to do two a week?
He said, that's what you gotta do.
He just said he...
He's just so good at like...
He's also like such a great salesman.
He's so convincing 'cause he has all the tactics down.
'Cause he's just like, "Yeah, right."
He's like, "You know, I know."
He's like, "It nearly destroyed my family."
He's like, you know--
This is what you gotta do.
And he was just like, and he's like yeah.
And then was just like, "Look, you know, if it's just
"like a fun hobby thing for you, that's fine.
"But like, if you wanna support your family
"and like get a new engine for your truck and stuff,
"yeah, you gotta just suck it up."
And then he's funny about it.
And he's like, yeah, he's like, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I can tell you stuff off camera that he says
that's unbelievable, man.
But yeah, the pace, the pace is very...
It's brutal, right.
It's brutal, it's brutal, but I'm gonna get faster.
I'm getting faster.
Doing it all yourself.
Well, you're in the doing of it.
It's informing how you iterate on it
to make it sustainable for you.
But you don't wanna destroy your life in the meantime.
I bet meetings will make me faster,
going to meetings again and like that reset, I think.
And then I got some equipment that makes me faster.
I got a big iMac with the big screen and like the 10 core.
You know, they don't get faster, they don't get faster.
Just the software gets bigger 'cause I'm shooting 4K now,
it's just as slow as the other thing.
Right 'cause the resolution increases in lockstep
with limitations of the actual computing power.
Lightening speed.
How come I'm waiting 40 minutes to render this two minute--
Well, that's another video idea right there.
Thank you.
Oh, another thing about being in my like late 40s now,
like ideas used to be so important to me,
like I had to be in a...
I take them all.
People are like, "Moving closer to this."
I was like, "Okay, sobriety, that, wasn't my idea.
"That was in the comments."
So it was like, make a movie about it, I was like, okay.
But you say like your, you know, Casey does action
and drama and comedy and you're introspection,
but there is a drawl kind of self-referential comedy
like low key in your videos.
Like when you're like, it only took me seven days
or something like that--
(speakers talking over each other)
Self awareness around that.
There's a bunch of little Easter egg jokes too
that you have to really...
And when people get them, I'm like,
"Oh my God, they got it."
Like in the...
Did you see the one I did for UNICEF?
Yes.
The one you just put that up today or yesterday?
Yesterday.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, it took two days to make this 15 second video
but that's okay 'cause it was for the kids, you know.
It's taken you two days.
I would've never been able to accomplish that in a million.
I'm more likely to get an invitation to come
to the White House than create what you created
in that 15 second video.
But the only dialogue I said, it took two days
and I was like, I said something like...
But that didn't matter 'cause it was all about the kids,
which was I stole a line from casino.
And the first comment on that video is like,
"Is this line from Casino with then Joe Pesci is talking
about his kid and the little league team?
I wrote right back "Oh my God, this is the first comment.
"Unbelievable that you got I," that's really satisfying.
I also put in, "No one's gotten it."
I don't know that anyone's got.
There was this thing where I'm doing the running thing
and I'm talking about the dad and the son that I run into
on my run and I said, I hope they're training,
or maybe they're training for something.
And I go some kind of race or something,
like that which is this very subtle reference
to Linda Mans, I think is her name
who does the narration for "Days of Heaven."
Did you ever see that movie?
Yeah, forever ago.
And she's talking about how the farmer was getting better.
He was supposed to die but he was getting better.
And he was like, "Maybe the doctor gave him something.
"Some kind of medicine or something."
No, I couldn't get that.
I put that in there so Josh Safdie would get it.
So for one person I put that line and I'm like,
"Josh will get this," but I don't know if he's got it yet.
Quite a career, those guys are having right now.
Oh my God.
Have you met these guys?
No.
Oh, my God, these, I love them so much.
Well-deserved, I mean, talk about an original voice.
Oh, oh my God.
It's unbelievable that they're brothers too.
I feel like Josh gets more like, he gets lauded more.
Maybe not, maybe I'm wrong 'cause I don't know.
But Ben is unbelievable because he has the performance side.
He's like an unbelievable performer.
Did you see "Good Time?"
Yeah, of course.
When he's like--
Yeah, that movie is crazy.
Don't count your chickens before they hatch.
What does that mean to you?
Don't count chickens.
That's like the first line of the movie.
And they wrote it, they came up with that.
Yeah, those guys.
Don't they also, did they found
or did they own that little tiny museum
where you did the thing?
Okay, Josh and this guy named Alex Calman
who's another one.
I mean, does Casey talked to you about the Diane Fink School
in New York?
No.
Okay.
Someday we will know about this.
Someday this, and maybe this is something for me to make.
Maybe this is something for me to make.
Maybe I should do this.
Maybe I should take a year and make this
just in little YouTube videos.
So there was after September 11th, 2001,
there were all these subsidies for buildings
south of canal street, because the air was poisoned
with mercury.
So nobody wanted to--
How do you get people to go back down there?
Yes, like how do we get (indistinct)?
Make the rents cheap.
So we got this amazing deal on this building
and 368 Broadway.
Oh, that's how that happened?
Yes, 'cause I think we got that building in 2004, I think,
or 2003 I think we've started renting that little space.
And so our buddies started renting spaces
in that same building and then across the street,
like directly, but we can look into their window,
Yaniv Schulman and his brother Ariel Schulman
and Henry Joost.
Henry Joost and Ariel Schulman are directors.
They just directed the power project with Jamie Fox.
They're like big Hollywood producers.
Yeah, now they are people listening who those names
don't sound familiar, there are the guys behind "Catfish."
That's right--
That was really established this.
Lena Dunham was in the building too, right.
Like there was all kinds of people.
Yes, we all have the same landlord.
Her name was Diane Fink and Henry Joost said,
"Yeah, that's the Diane Fink School."
That's not all, Greta Gerwig.
Sam Lutsenko, who's a...
He's like a production designer, art director.
Josh and Ben Safdie, Alex Calman who did the little museum
who's had shows at the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
Yeah, Lena Dunham rented a space Carlton to Woody.
That's crazy.
So many and we were all (indistinct)
(speakers talking over each other)
That's like the quintessential New York like factory,
like cauldron of creativity.
If you've ever seen that movie.
Oh, what's the movie with?
It's black and white, it's Noah Birnbaum
and Greta Gerwig was this star.
Baumbach, Baumbach.
Baumbach.
Noah Baumbach.
He wrote it and directed it.
Greta Gerwig is the star, it's black and white.
I can't remember the name of it.
Do you remember the name of it?
No, let me, I can look it up.
Okay, well I'll just tell you what I'm getting at.
That movie is that scene is...
I can tell the guy, the...
No.
What's it called?
Oh, did you find it?
No, hold on, I'm looking it up. Keep talking.
So that movie is...
Okay, so the guy who's from star...
I can't, I'm so bad with names.
Adam...
Adam Driver.
Adam Driver, that's a combination of Yaniv Schulman
and Ariel Shullman.
No way.
Okay, so the guy who's writing "Gremlins," Gremlins III"
the guy who's writing the script for "Gremlins III"
that's Sam Lysenko.
Wow.
And all those people are people from that little world,
from this Diane Fink's group.
And Francis Ho, how long ago was that--
Francis Ho, that's right, Francis Ho.
I remember watching it and then Mickey Sumner,
she's one of us, she's also in the movie.
And I just remember watching this and being like,
"Oh my God, we're like this community,
"this like little gang of people."
This is like--
Somebody should write a book about that
or make a documentary.
Just like "Call 368, I mean, that's an amazing thing.
It's super cool, it's super, super cool.
I didn't know that.
I mean, I knew there were some cool people in the building
but I didn't realize the full extent of it.
I mean, I'm leaving people out.
There's Brett Jukkawits who's a cinematographer.
There's a...
I'm leaving people out.
There's, I mean, if the was one other person from there
if Casey was here, he'd be able to name them.
I'm sure, right.
But it was astonishing and it was all--
And everybody's hanging out and going into like,
is that what led to the wall of Polaroids
with all the people in the studio?
Yeah, that was...
I don't know, I don't know.
I don't remember where that came from.
I think that came from when you would go to our friends,
we have a friend named Cynthia Rally
and she's like a big fashion designer.
And when you go to designers when they're doing their looks,
they do the Polaroids and they put them on the walls
of all the different outfits.
I think that comes from that maybe, I don't really remember,
but that was a cool idea.
But explain that museum, like it's M Museum or something,
it's literally just a closet that goes out
that opens to an alley.
Yeah, I think it's 80 square feet, it's like 10 by eight.
And it's filled with all these incredible--
Is it still there?
It's still there and it's filled with all these incredible
artifacts, like the shows have.
Now they have like really kind of tight themes.
It's mmuseumm.com, it's really unbelievable by the book.
The book is unbelievably great.
And Alex Calman, his mother is Myra Calman
who's an artist who is incredible.
And she did like New Yorker covers and writes books.
And then his father was, oh gosh.
His father was something Calman and oh, I can't believe,
I can't remember his name, I'm so embarrassed.
And he is a very pioneering, innovative designer
and advertising guy.
And you know who he is because he did, I think he did 100%
of "The Talking Heads" album covers among other things.
And he also is responsible.
His company was called M@Co and they made these umbrellas
that had blue skies on the inside.
Oh wow.
And so that's his project and it was started with Josh,
Safdie and Alex Calman, and then Alex took it over
and yeah, it's unbelievable.
They did a show where it was all artifacts
smuggled in from Syria, like from Syrian refugees.
It's incredible.
You did a thing there, didn't you where you would sit down
and talk to people for like a half an hour
and then carve a word into a Swiss army knife.
Okay, look, so I...
I did this for, so I take a Swiss army knife
and a wood burner and I in an grave with the wood burner,
I melt the plastic and so I have one in my hand here
and it's like I wrote V Neistat on one side
and then on the other side, I wrote a date 10/03/12
and that was the date that that show ended.
And I did this for a picture 'cause one of my rewards
for my Kickstarter campaign was that one of these knives.
So I have to make like 100 of them or something, anyhow--
The burdens of being a Youtuber.
And then it was a real gold leaf paint
that it's in embossed in.
And so I set up this little desk which I made
that was all compartmentalized
and it held all of the equipment inside of it
and it had a handle and I set it up in that little museum
and I wore a suit.
And then people would come in and for awhile,
I was giving these out as presence, the Swiss champ
which is like the Mac daddy Swiss army knife
with the pliers in it and the magnifying glass
and everything.
Right, for people that are listening,
that's the super thick one.
Yeah, and so I would do the first initial
and then the last name on one side of the knife.
And then what I called the golden word on the other knife.
And it was just some word that would resonate
with the person I was giving it to.
So I should give an example, but I can't think,
I have a whole list of hundreds of them but I can't.
So I just did this show and I donated
a bunch of the proceeds to the museum
so that they could pay their rent for like the year
'cause of rent is like 100 bucks a month or something
because it's just a closet.
And like I had all these people come and they would just...
They were buying it as a gift for someone
and then they would talk about this person
and I would just throw out words.
I would say, how about, like one of them I came up
with a person, was like that's perfect.
Was breadcrumbs.
And so, yeah, that went on for a month.
And so it's 10/03/12.
My sober date is September 8th, 2012,
so I was less than one month.
So my hands, 'cause I developed this stoned
and I would be steady as a rock.
I could do eyeball surgery.
My hands were so steady, so dialed in when I was stoned.
One of the reasons why I love getting stoned
is I was so good at making things.
The whole world would disappear
and I would just be there, I would just be so present.
So, a lot of it was about productivity
and being able to like do the thing.
It was all in service to doing the work.
So did you have that crisis when you were newly sober
of like, "I'm never gonna be able to do anything
"creative again?"
That big fear that--
No, because it's just, I didn't...
I was in the storm, I didn't have a choice.
There was no other way for me to make a living.
So it's like...
There's this scene in "Hearts of Darkness,"
have you seen this?
Yeah.
There's this scene where it's about the making
of "Apocalypse" now and Francis Ford Coppola
who's like 35 years old and he's like mortgaged his house
and everything to pay for this production in the monsoon,
is wiped out the set and the studio
stopped giving him money and Marlon brand
does not cooperate, everything's going wrong.
And he's in the Philippines
and there's a civil war going on.
And his wife secretly recorded with an audio recorder
his evening conversations and you hear one of them
and like Latraviata is playing in the background,
he's making spaghetti.
And you hear Coppola and he's saying,
he's like, "Yeah, so-and-so said am I gonna quit?"
He's like, "How can I quit, I can't quit."
He's like, "I can't quit, there's no way."
He's like, "I could put a bullet in my head
"and I mean, that's what it comes down to." There is no...
There's no other choice.
There's nothing else, it's worse.
I mean, of course it's better.
It's a good news, bad news thing.
Yeah, of course better.
And this is what, you know, they all tell you this
like Sachs told me this, Sachs is like,
"You know, when you're starting out."
He's like, "The first thing you do when you make
"a little money, spend every penny
"so that you have to keep going,
"you have to make the another thing."
And yeah, I don't know.
So my hands shook really badly when I was making the knives.
That's a story though that makes me feel nostalgic
for New York though, like it's a romantic New York story.
The thing about New York is most people's opinion
of New York, most people who've been to New York,
their opinion of New York is based on visiting New York.
Living on that.
How long did you live there?
I mean, it was two years right out of college.
So yeah, it was like four guys crashed out
in a room and a half.
That's the golden age.
Yeah, where you can get away with it
and it's just a good time.
And your apartment is just basically a locker.
Sure, 17 to 35, there's no other place like it.
It's fantastic.
Also, if you have a thing, I don't know if it's still
like this 'cause the internet is New York now.
But if you have a thing, a mission and you're like,
"I'm gonna do," even if it's vague
"I wanna make a lot of money, I wanna become an artist."
Even if it's vague, go there and don't stop
and you will do it because it is so hard--
And nothing else matters anyway if you're driven
in that way, it doesn't matter what your apartment
looks like or if you're only eating dollar slices of pizza.
But to live there and I've never lived there rich
and I'll bet living there rich is amazing,
like, I think Casey might move back.
I'm sure he's gonna move back.
Because his life there, like, I mean, it's no secret
that that kid has like a lot of money and his life there
is like luxury apartment, Battery Park city,
which is isolated from the rest of Manhattan
by the west side highway.
But it's also its own little village with a movie theater
and a mall that has all of the greatest stores
and restaurants in existence in it.
It has views of the statue of Liberty, it's clean.
They keep all the homeless people out with private security.
It's got a park, it's got the west side bike path
that runs through it, it's perfect.
You can keep your car, your like land Rover in the basement
in a heated thing.
You don't need to take your slippers off,
you don't need to leave, like, yeah, that is cool.
And you can get on the private plane,
you can charter a private plane
and fly to your house in Nantucket.
Yeah, that's cool.
But if you're a regular guy, if you're a regular
like middle-class person and you're living in New York
and you're doing the grind and you're dependent
on the subway and the--
It's hard.
And you have a family, it's not worth it.
I'm sorry, it's not.
And I think past like and in my 40s,
it very nearly killed me
very difficult place, very difficult place.
So here to stay in LA.
And LA is the greatest city in the world.
And Werner Hertzog in person said to me,
Los Angeles is the most vital city in the world.
When did he say that to you?
This was in 2018 or 19.
You gotta walk me through how you ended up
in a conversation with Werner Hertzog.
Okay, so...
And like maybe a little background
on like the fan boy fascination with this remarkable human.
With Hertzog?
Yeah, he's the best.
Okay, so this is what it is.
How did we find out?
I think Tom Sachs told me about Hertzog, I think.
And we were making this piece for Sachs called "Toyons"
and it was the largest boombox in the world.
And I think it had a hundred thousand watts of amplifiers
and it was 220, it wasn't 110.
It was like that there was so much amperage
that they had to use a different...
They had to use like the kind of voltage
that you use in a washing machine or maybe it was 110
and then somebody connected it to 220 and the whole thing.
Anyway, the thing was huge, it probably weighed over a ton.
And we had to move it from Tom's studio
to this amazing warehouse Hester street
that's now luxury apartments.
And it was like two or three blocks
but you have to negotiate traffic.
And this is the legend in my mind, it's probably not true.
This isn't probably what happened
but I think Tom put on his required viewing list
to watch this movie called "Burden of Dreams."
And it is a Wes Blank film about Werner Hertzog
making "Fitzcarraldo."
And in the making of "Fitzcarraldo'
I believe Werner Hertzog was five years old
and he was making it the way that we make films.
Like just a few people, camera guy, blah, blah, blah
not all the trailers and stuff.
And he was in Peru and sort of the central theme
of the movie was this man with this dream
of bringing opera to the Amazon rain forest.
And in order to do it, he needed to bring this gigantic ship
over a mountain to a different river
so that he could get rubber and bring it down to,
it was like when the, during the rubber boom
and that's how he was gonna afford to buy the opera house.
I believe that's the premise of the movie
and it was based on a guy who actually did bring
a boat over a mountain, but he took the boat apart,
the guy who did it in real life
and the mountain wasn't as steep
as the one that Hertzog did.
So Hertzog, it took him 10 years to make this movie
and with just rudimentary levers and so forth
and rope and native people, they brought this,
like I don't know how many hundred ton ship
over a pretty steep mucky mountain.
They really did it for this film and I think Sachs
had us watch it because it's like,
"Okay, look guys, if you're gonna get into this business,
"this is this business.
"This is what this business is.
"And this guy this guy is doing something
"that is impossible."
It's not possible, you can't do this.
And I made a movie called "Toyons Burden"
and it takes audio from the "Burden of Dreams"
and it's about us moving this boombox down into the thing.
And in that movie, Hertzog talks about the jungle
working in the jungle.
And he's like, people talk about the harmony of the jungle.
And he's like there is no harmony,
but if there is a harmony
it's the harmony of collective murder.
That's such a classic in his drolded hand.
And so my whole voiceover 'cause I write all those facts,
movies, I wrote all those voiceovers and I delivered them.
But I'm just channeling him, his style.
He's just such a master at making little ironic things
and putting in these little incredible jokes.
But with such reverence that you could miss it.
And so we made this movie, Tom Sachs and I.
We made a movie called "10 Bullets"
which is basically about how to behave on a job.
When you have a job, these are the 10 things
that you should do.
Be on time, keep a list, there's 10 of them, 10 bullets.
It's incredible.
And we made a sequel to it that was written
by Alex Chohlas-Woods.
And it was called "The Fear Bullets"
and it was for managers.
And it was about like one of those bullets
was like never yell under any circumstances.
And so Tom and I, it took us years to write the sequel
and we wrote part of it and we went to Japan,
we went to this place called own Anomichi in Japan
and had like a very peaceful time.
We took the bullet train there from Tokyo and we very slowly
teased out this movie.
And one of us had this idea is like,
it's not the fear bullets, the bullets were these,
what we're getting at in all of these bullets
is that when you get to a certain level with your work,
there's a certain level that you get to in your endeavors
where your skill is so good that you reach these paradoxes
where you are entrapped in a paradox
and you have to pick the left versus the right
and they're both right and they're both wrong.
And so we wrote this script for a movie called
"Paradox Bullets."
And I can't remember how many there are,
I don't think there were 10, I think there were six.
And like one of them was like, never give up,
know when to quit, that was one of the bullets.
Do the hard thing first, do the hard thing last,
or do the hard thing first, do the easy thing first.
And so I did the first voiceover.
And Mario Sorrenti, who's...
He's a photographer.
He's a photographer, he discovered Kate Moss,
but he's a photographer and he's a friend of Tom's studios
and I consider him a friend of mine.
And his wife has common law wife is Mary Fry
and she's also a friend of studio...
Anyway, Mario Sorrenti said, "You should get Hertzog.
"You should get Hertzog to do this."
And we were like, "How are we gonna get Hertzog?"
And Mario's like, "Just figure out how to pay him,
"just figure it out."
And so Tom got Nike to pay for the movie
and so I don't know what the deal transpired
but we got Hertzog to do it.
And at the end of the movie, he added a line
and it was to the bullet that was...
Oh, God, if I was my mom, I would know this detail.
I could remember this detail.
Is it online, can you find it on?
Yeah, yeah, it's online.
It was something about how we work in...
It was something like follow irrational ideas
with as as rationally and logically as possible.
And so we get to the end of that bullet
and then Hertzog in the studio, in the booth
doing the voiceover says something like
otherwise we are no better than the cow in the field.
And that day was unbelievable because I had...
You know, when I do my voiceover, I am channeling him.
I am channeling.
I'm like, "Okay, that is the pin.
"That's as high as you can get with voiceover."
The spirited man.
And so to hear him, he's reading my words
and it sounds exactly like a Hertzog film.
And I don't know it was, I don't know what that is.
It's like, I don't know.
'Cause it can't be anything else if he was reading it.
Yeah.
I don't know, it's just, I don't know.
But I wrote the words, you know what I mean?
That's unbelievable.
It was like a, I don't know, I felt like a little kid
or something, I don't know.
It was really, really, really cool.
For people that are less familiar with his work,
I love the stuff about the Werner Hertzog film school,
just basically like with no money, find your way
across Europe and get a job, like all this crazy stuff.
Like this is your film school basically like go live a life
of adventure and hardship.
Yeah.
Yeah, he said the application process
is you have to walk a tremendous number of miles to me.
Keep a journal every day.
And by reading it, I'll know if you were lying.
Because there's a famous story of this.
He was in, I can't remember, he was in like Munich
or something and a very close friend of his
who was a film critic, I think her name was Lottie
something was dying.
And she said, "I have two months to live, Werner,
"I have cancer."
And he said, "Do not die before I get to you,
"I'm coming to you, do not die."
And he walked.
So it took him months and months and months.
So she kept living and then she went on to live years
and years after that.
And he wrote, I think it's called,
"Walking Through Fire and Ice" is the name of the book.
I was like...
That's crazy.
I don't know, he's unbelievable.
He bought us fish and chips.
He scheduled four hours for the voiceover
but his game is so tight and our game is so tight.
It took us 30 minutes.
And so after he showed us a cut of his film without music
and then he talked to his editor, he was like,
"I want you to look up."
And then he was like, "Georgian wedding hymns."
And the kids just like, and he looks it up and he plays it.
And he's like, "Okay, plug that in."
And we're watching this movie and I'm watching it.
And I'm like, without the music, it's like
I'm like looking at Sachs and I'm like (indistinct).
This is Hertzog.
And he puts the music in it and you're like, holy shit.
And it was just amazed.
I mean, I get to see the guy, you got to see him
doing the thing, but...
That's cool.
You know, he's still doing it like the YouTube way.
I know, right.
Suitcase with cameras and just, he shoots and no permits.
He says, in essential filmmaking school
is the ability to forge documents,
to make counterfeit documents.
Yeah, yeah, that's his whole thing.
And he had one, he was shooting in Peru.
He had it signed by like the president of Peru.
He just forged the signature and he hands it to the Colonel
or whatever and they're just like (indistinct).
I know, what a gift that guy is.
Oh my God, he's so good.
I just watched some...
Oh, I watched "My Best Fiend" I had never seen it.
I haven't seen that.
That's about his relationship with Klaus Kinski
who was the star of Fitzcarraldo, he played Fitzcarraldo
and he was absolute maniac.
Yeah, I'll check that out.
Well, let's round this out, but I can't end it
without a few thoughts on just this idea
of the spirited man.
Like where does it come from
and what does it mean to you personally?
Okay, so where it comes from is this book
by Matthew B. Crawford and it's called
"Shop Class As Soul Craft."
And Matthew B. Crawford is a writer and he started out
he had a PhD from, I can't remember,
I think maybe University of Chicago in philosophy.
And he worked at think tanks, made a lot of money consulting
like I think big corporations and executives
but his real love was working on vintage motorcycles.
And he was like, he raced his Volkswagen beetle
when he was a kid.
And he wrote this book called "Shop Class As Soul Craft.
And it's about the kind of like intellectual significance
of working with one's hands, of making things
with one's hands.
And I read it, I think I read it in two...
I think it came out in 2009,
I might've read it in 2011 or something like that.
And it was an incredible relief
to know that there were people out there
that were like bookworms and they were tinkerer people
like me who liked to mess around with machines and stuff.
And this was that, and this is like the book about it.
And he has a chapter where he's talking
about how the new cars, you need millions of dollars
worth of diagnostic equipment to figure out
what's wrong with them.
And you plug in a USB into your seven series BMW
and all this stuff comes out.
And he said something like the spirited man needs to know
exactly what's wrong with his car or something like that.
Or like, you know, and then he went on to talk
about basically that the spirited man is a man
who can take care of his own stuff.
And so that's to me, what it is, is the spirit of man
is a man who, I said it in one of the episodes,
is a man who takes care of his own business.
So that's what it is.
It's also, it it's this discomfort or intolerance
for asymmetry in the universe.
When there's something off, like you walked into our studio
and immediately gravitated towards this corner
where we have a bunch of stuff stacked
and you're like, that is unacceptable, right?
It's not so much--
It's very expensive stuff.
It's not like a...
I'm sure a lot of people would call it like an OCD.
It's more like a hypervigilance and a sensitivity
to this idea that there's a right way of doing things.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not okay to slack off on that.
Like there is valor in doing things properly.
You know, we live in this era, this, this era.
Have you read "The Fourth Turning," do you know that book?
No, but I saw your book report.
It's so good.
'Cause these guys are financial guys
and you can trust these guys.
I know it sounds weird.
These financial guys, they make these predictions.
They say, "Okay, these trends exist"
and then they make money off of it
which is the hardest thing to do.
So in my mind, you can listen to these guys.
These words have weight like Ray Dalio,
yeah, he can predict the future, he's good at it.
He's been doing it for 50 years.
So one of the things that this guy says
is people in our generation, Gen X
and we also line up with the lost generation.
That's the same generation and that history slot,
Hemingway and all those guys, they were X-ers of their time.
We grew up in a time of post-war very rich unraveling time
where kind of anything went, right?
And one of the conclusions that I drew with anything goes
is, no, that's not true.
Anything goes provided certain things are perfect.
And I don't know, to me my whole being able to wrestle
my craziness into something productive
was all because of me learning all disciplines,
learning techniques and learning things
that aren't negotiable.
Sometimes as a creative person you think,
"Oh, I can re blah, blah, blah.
"I don't need the three-act structure.
"I don't need plot."
No, no, no, no, what thousands of years of innovation
and you're exception to thousands of years of Plato
and Socrates and all these people having to follow
these rules, but you don't. No, no, no, no, no, no.
And I think, I don't know, maybe these are sort of
the little, these are the little things
that are just the residue of me learning that stuff
the absolute hard way.
But how does that square with "The Fourth Turning"
in the sense that you're yourself as a cog in a machine
that's kind of progressing towards this dismantling
as we progress towards 2028, like we're in this age
of basically an unraveling of sorts,
a destruction, a reckoning.
No, no, no, crisis, we're in the crisis.
Unraveling is what we grew up in.
The unraveling was 1960.
Okay, no, 1984, maybe 1988 end of Reagan to 2008,
that was the unraveling, now we're in the crisis.
But before the unraveling is the awakening
and that's the starts in '63 when the assassination of...
But one of the characteristics of our generation
throughout history, you can go back to civil war, all that
is that we are a repair generation
and we are the ones that say, no, no, no, no, no
you have to save this.
You have to save these institutions.
This is a value.
And reading that book and reading the other one,
the Matthew B. Crawford book, "Shop Class As Soul Craft"
and frankly, listening to certain Jordan Peterson lectures,
it made me very comfortable with the fact of like,
it would be artistically rewarding and valuable to isolate
to like really narrowly focus on your propensity
to repair in a very literal sense.
And if you are literal and precise enough about it
then it will have a universal resonance with people.
And so I try not to be self-conscious or perceptive,
like that's all subconscious stuff that I learn
after I've made the thing.
I try to just really dial in like, these little details,
I just try to really dial into them
and then just trust that in writing the words
that I'm gonna narrate, that it will have
some kind of universal,
there'll be some universal power in it.
But the thing I'm trying to...
I think the thing that I'm consciously trying to talk about
is that there are things that we have to preserve
and there are very valuable things and many great people
gave lives and stuff to bring us this thing,
the civilization that we live in
and it's unbelievably great, it's unbelievably good.
And look, I hate it just as much as everybody else
and I bet you about it.
And I hate that my fucking AirPod pros do not sync up
every time.
It's like you are a trillion dollar company,
solve that problem please.
How about when you publish a podcast
and it doesn't show up in the fucking app for like 40 hours?
Yeah, that's--
Unacceptable.
That's hospitalization for me.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, it speaks to you, reading that and seeing that
must have been like, I've never felt so heard in my life.
Like now I can fulfill my destiny as a repairman
and preach and speak to this idea of preservation
and an appreciation for the tactile and the analog
because these things do have meaning,
especially as we hurdle towards this disposable culture
where everything gets thrown away.
I mean, and it's almost not, like responsibility
doesn't always fall on the individual shoulders.
Like my daughter has a record player
and she said to me the other day, like,
"Can we go get this fixed, it's broken."
How old is she?
13.
Okay.
And I said, yeah, of course.
I said, "I want you to go online and I want you to find
"a place that will repair it and then call me."
Right, yeah.
So the reply is Guitar Center.
I know Guitar Center is not gonna repair a record player.
And I said, "I want you to call a Guitar Center
"and ask them that question," figure out,
like we did find a place in Woodland Hills
that does audio repair.
Wonderful.
So we're gonna go have this experience, right?
So we take this record player that's probably worth $65.
It's not a high end thing, it's intended to be disposable
but we're gonna try to repair it.
The repair shop requires $50 just to look at it
and then 10 days before they actually give you a diagnosis
and tell you whether they can even fix it
and what that is gonna look like.
So we're in the waiting phase now but my prognosis
is that they're either not gonna be able to fix it
or the cost of fixing it is gonna so exceed the value
of the thing itself that it doesn't make economic sense
to do it.
So you think.
What?
The cost of fixing it will exceed the value
of the thing itself.
That's where, I mean, that's where,
I mean that I wrestle with, that's basically like my life
is wrestling with that and the truck,
my truck is the embodiment of that.
Right, but your truck is...
If you wanna be rational about it, you're right.
And if you wanna be rational about it,
throw that thing in the garbage can and go get an iPhone.
But this isn't a rational thing that you're doing,
it's irrational to do that record player.
That's not rational.
That makes my point that it isn't the individual's fault
for not adopting a sensibility like yours
because you have to be irrational to do it.
Not at all, not at all.
No, this is, it's a gift. It's a gift, I have a gift.
I've been like this always
since I was a little baby, I've been like this, it's a gift.
And I'm grateful for it.
And I don't know, I don't know what to say.
I don't know what to say beyond that
but I've exploited it and it's yeah.
I don't think you're exploiting it, you're expressing it.
And you're doing it beautifully.
And I think that's probably a good place to end it.
Anything else you wanna say?
Any final?
Well, no, but nothing, but thank you for having me
and thanks for the coffee, it was very good.
Yeah, super fun talking to you.
Everybody definitely go check out "The Spirited Man"
on YouTube, subscribe immediately and enjoy
two videos a week.
How many do you have, like 16 or 17 or something like that?
I think I'm in the 20s, maybe 24.
You're on your way.
Yeah.
Let's go to a meeting in the meantime.
Okay.
All right, cool.
Thanks man.
Thank you.
Peace.
(upbeat music)